fiona c'est la fin des vendanges à
l'ancienne à rivarennes en indre et
loire
le dernier exploitant qui vendange à la
main part à la retraite et c'est tout un
patrimoine qui s'en va reportage en
touraine nathanaël le maire marc tenir
cette façon de faire les vendanges est
en voie de disparition
ces deux hectares de vignes en
appellation touraine azay-le-rideau
n'ont jamais vu l'ombre d'une machine
chez les le mail on travaille le raisin
de la même façon depuis des générations
seulement ces vendanges à l'ancienne
sont les dernières le viticulteur par la
retraite il ya pas de repreneur pour
prendre des bus ici appuyer plus de gens
qui me le faire du vin on est une petite
appellera sous peu sur l arène où
j'arrivais à beaucoup de fruits mais
puériculteurs avec juste quelques
hectares et invendus 0,25 euro le litre
les cépages grelots gamme et n'intéresse
plus personne
avec l'arrachage de ce petit bout de
vignobles c'est toute une tradition qui
disparaît pour ceux qui vont dans gysi
depuis leur enfance
c'est le patrimoine
quand on nous parle du patrimoine ça
n'en fait partie pendant et à la main
quand il y aura pu tout ça ça bien
triste vous savez et malheureusement il
y aura pu tout ça c'est toute une
ambiance c'était la belle vie
ça me fait quelque chose quand même
parce que bah c'est une tradition qui
s'en va c'est une chose en rouge on a 40
et peu gros quand même vraiment comme il
voulait tout à l'heure et qui y est au
moyen de faire autrement donc faut il
penser quoi dans la ferme pas de cuve en
inox pas très soir mécanique mais des
barriques en bois qu'on remplit encore à
la mince comme depuis la nuit des temps
moi je pense que c'est d'abord c'est ma
dernière année est d'abord m'a aidé et
puis voilà j'espère la première parce
que comme ces dernières années